hi I'm Bart Gilman and I won't spend a
long time introducing our panelists
you've got biographies uh
uh before we start everyone please take
the battery out of your cell phone uh if
you have an Apple device you could just
smash it with a hammer and you could do
this at home also if you're tweeting we
have a hashtag tracking con
the last panel focused on primarily on
Fourth Amendment and we will touch on
that here for sure as well but we're
going to begin with
a an explanation from Kevin bankson of a
quite complex
set of statutory uh
instruments involved in location
tracking uh and uh I'm going to take it
to you Kevin okay um so hi I'm Kevin uh
and I've been given the task of laying
out the sort of basic history and legal
framework of the issue of government
requests uh to sell carriers uh I'm a
lawyer I I'm a free expression director
at the center for democracy and
technology in DC uh but I used to work
the surveillance beat at the Electronic
Frontier Foundation until last year and
it's because of that work that uh Margot
and Yale ISP invited me to be here Margo
actually being an eff Alum and thank you
for letting me be here uh and walk down
memory lane on this issue that I spent a
number of years on
um
walking down memory lane I in particular
I'm given the opportunity to revisit
what is probably my favorite week as a
lawyer uh or my best week as a lawyer uh
in December 2010
um because not only uh not only is was
it a great week for me it provides an
interesting lens where we can approach
the challenges the unique challenges of
trying to strengthen and clarify the
standards when it comes to government
access to phone records cell phone
location records and uh government
tracking of your cell phone in real time
so
let's go back in time uh to December
14th 2010 uh a Tuesday a really great
Tuesday because we got a landmark ruling
not on cell phone tracking
um but on email privacy the sixth
circuit ruled in line with arguments
made in an eff Amicus brief joined by
ACLU and CDT
um held that we have a reasonable
expectation of privacy in the email we
store in the cloud
um and and found that the stored
Communications act portion of the
Electronic Communications Privacy Act
which uh in certain circumstances
allowed warrantless access to email was
unconstitutional
um so it was a really great Tuesday and
Tuesdays usually stink at eff because
that's when we have a bunch of like
weekly meetings and it's really kind of
a drag
um but you know the good times didn't
stop because the very next day bam
Wednesday another win
this one was related to cell tracking
um in the very first appellate case to
consider what privacy protections apply
to your cell phone location records held
by your carrier
in a case that Susan freewall denied
both argued during a particularly
stressful and snowbound week in
Philadelphia uh in February 2010 notably
against our very close Frenemy Mark
eckenweiler formerly of doj who we were
hoping was going to be here today but
couldn't make it
um we again with our koamiki ACLU and
CDT won a great victory in that case
awkwardly titled in the matter of the
application of the USA for an order
directing a provider of electronic
Communication Service to disclose
records to the government say that three
times fast the third circuit onbank
refused to review the panel Court
decision which had upheld a decision by
a federal magistrate in Pittsburgh just
Lenahan judge Lenahan had taken the very
rare step of rejecting in a public
opinion a government secret application
to obtain cell site location information
or cslis as as the wonks sometimes call
it csli records in a drug investigation
without a probable cause warrant and so
in other words we learned that day that
our victory in front of the third
circuit would stand and so another great
day
but then the next day bam it was just
another Thursday but it's okay because
otherwise it was a really good week
um
so why am I telling you this other than
self-congratulation there is a reason in
fact there are two
um one is a message to the law students
in the audience
um it is an advertisement for working at
places like eff and CDT and ACLU on
these kinds of issues because you know
when you're in non-profit you're going
to lose a lot in fact that's kind of the
job description because if you're not
losing you're not picking your fights
right you're not picking the important
cases but sometimes you're going to win
sometimes you're going to win big and
it's going to feel really great it's
going to really kick ass and so pardon
my French but it's kick ass when you win
like that and it was a great week so the
other reason I'm telling you about this
is because
um when you compare and contrast these
two cases these two victories they're
instructive they they sort of help give
us a lens to understand the challenge
that we face on location tracking so
first the similarities
um in both cases the government sought
data and in warshok they got it with
some something react big Geeks call a d
order after 18 USC
2703d it's a court order for getting
stored content or records and it's kind
of like a warrant but unlike a warrant
it doesn't require a showing of probable
cause and instead it requires are
showing only that the information sought
is uh relevant and material to an
investigation a lower standard
also in both cases the government relied
uh argued that it didn't need a warrant
based on two key Supreme Court cases
from the 70s
that each held that the respective
information in those cases wasn't
protected by the Fourth Amendment
because we had knowingly exposed it to a
third party and therefore had assumed
the risk those parties would hand it
over those cases are USV Miller which
found no reasonable expectation of
privacy and bank records and Smith V
Maryland which found no reasonable
expectation of privacy against pen
register surveillance of the phone
numbers you've dialed the pen registers
came up in the previous session as well
um so the difference is
um well in warshok we had great
analogies
um first off we had the analogy to the
private content of our phone calls which
is really strongly protected under a
couple of landmark electronic
eavesdropping rulings from the 60s uh
USB cats in Burgerville New York
um there was also analogy to the privacy
of our physical postal mail uh analogy
to the privacy of the files we keep in
our home or at least did until we had
the cloud we also had a statute that was
clear there is no question that the
stored Communications act allows the
government to get a whole lot of email
without a warrant based on some pretty
senseless distinctions that are
themselves based on the way technology
worked in 1986 when the statute was
written most notably and arbitrarily the
statute uh requires warrants for email
less than 180 days old but not for email
over 180 days old if you'd like to have
a drink after the conference and talk
about why that is I'd be happy to chat
with you about it but in the meantime
you combine that Clarity the clear
analogies to previous constitutional
precedent and the clear statute and you
got something that was further clear
that that statute was unconstitutional
and the court agreed with us and the doj
perhaps scared that they might make
their situation worse didn't even bother
to seek on Bonk review of this opinion
uh much less go for cert
and since then this ruling has paid off
Big Time first off everyone's requiring
warrants now Google Microsoft Yahoo
Facebook even Twitter I shouldn't say
even they're great on these issues
um they all require the government to
come back with a warrant uh when the
government wants to compel the
disclosure of stored content
um again and notably the doj hasn't
picked this fight in litigation or
appealed uh any any case like this they
appear to be choosing not to risk
another loss and in the meantime we're
getting a de facto rule of warrants for
Content across the country
meanwhile Warsaw also provided a great
boost for the digital due process
Coalition effort this is a equiform
coalition led by CDT bringing together
pretty much all the orgs and at this
point all the big internet companies uh
to modernize ecpa both on the content
issue and the location issue and so
warshok has been a really great Boon to
uh the push to codify a strong warrant
requirement for Content something that
we think might might actually knock on
wood past this year
um
this third circuit case on Cell tracking
on the other hand didn't give us this
kind of clarity hasn't yielded these
kinds of dividends instead we're sort of
at a standstill and there are a few
reasons for this first off the analogies
are much less helpful
um it's a lot easier to analogize cell
tower records to unprotected dialing
information or to bank records than it
is to the private contents of your
Communications although we did succeed
in convincing the court that that was
not an apt analogy that because we don't
actually knowingly expose or directly
communicate our location to our phone
company so there's the third circuit
found after we argue there's no knowing
exposure leading to an assumption of the
risk in Fourth Amendment terms
um second the decision itself is a lot
more cabined and conditional and
contingent than the warshok decision it
didn't hold that the statute or the
fourth amendment requires a warrant for
cell site location information
um instead it held that the statute
which is admittedly ambiguous about how
it treats location cave magistrates the
discretion to require a warrant in order
to avoid the hard Fourth Amendment
question and then hinted that the
records might might be protected by the
Fourth Amendment if they're precise
enough to place you inside of a home
basing this on on a couple of key uh
location tracking cases from the 80s
carowind knots
um
third the decision hasn't really given a
whole lot of new juice to the DDP push
to reform location tracking in ekpa
um the content fight is going well but
um things have been pretty quiet on the
location privacy front even with the
help of USV Jones uh in part this is
because there's there's still some
disagreement about whether warrants are
actually the appropriate standard for
stored records some including Stephanie
and Chris uh so goyan have have argued
at least as a matter of political
expediency that we shouldn't be pushing
A a warrant requirement for sword
records but instead should improve the
de-order standard in part it's because
of vigorous opposition from The doj Who
on this are unburdened by obvious
absurdities like a 180 day rule
um and in part it's just because it's a
really hard drafting problem with the
content stuff you can basically just
tweak ekba with the location stuff you
kind of have to write a whole new
statute so fourth and finally when
you're contrasting these cases there's
unlike with the content stuff there's no
indication that doj or the magistrates
or the phone companies have really
changed what they're doing it seems like
the government is still using the orders
for stored records uh the magistrate uh
the companies are are still uh
responding to them and the magistrates
are still issuing them
um with the notable exception of the
gentleman to my right judge Smith who in
October 2010 denied a couple of the
order applications for 60 days worth of
tower location information
um based on the DC circuit decision that
was ultimately upheld in Jones based on
the third circuit opinion and based on
some really killer findings of fact uh
that were in turn in uh based in no
small part on a really great bit of
testimony by security expert Matt Blaise
you should Google for it it's a really
great piece of work
as was thank you Chris for for your
introduction on the basic Tech and
accuracy issues
um
also unlike the email context the doj is
not afraid to appeal its losses we are
awaiting a decision right now from the
fifth Circuit Court of Appeals where
judge Smith's opinions are uh being
reviewed they were argued uh in October
in New Orleans once again by eff this
time uh uh my former colleague hany
fakori and Susan again making an
appearance and arguing that the statute
allowed in the fourth amendment required
judge Smith to reject those applications
so
just I have five more minutes and in
that time I'm going to talk about the
issue we haven't gotten to yet which is
real time tracking as opposed to access
to records
um
and this is going to require a little
bit more history going back a little
further in time uh to 2005 and this
story also involves judge Smith who as
as one will say has been a troublemaker
on these issues in the best way uh for
quite a while
um back then many of us assumed
and we all know how that goes uh we
assume that due the extent the
government was tracking cell phones it
wasn't really clear that it was a
routine investigative technique at that
point we assumed they were getting
warrants
um we assume this because no other court
order under Equus seems to fit the bill
um so you have wiretap orders which are
real time but they're only for Content
not for location information that isn't
actually the content of a communication
between you and someone else and uh
there are pen register orders uh
discussed in the previous panel issued
under a really low standard so low in
fact that uh Congress in a law called
Kalia in the 90s explicitly said you
cannot rely solely on the pen register
statute if you want to track location
because it's too invasive in the pen
register order is too easy to get
um
and then finally there's the D order
that I mentioned earlier but that's
clearly inapplicable because that's in
the stored Communications act and that's
about getting access to stored records
um but in late 2005 two magistrate
judges uh took the unprecedented step of
publishing decisions denying secret
government applications uh to track in
real time uh cell phones without a
warrant and in doing so to our shock and
dismay they revealed that the government
had been routinely and for years
obtaining this Authority without
warrants
and instead using D orders
um which is just crazy because those are
for stored records but anyway those two
judges were judge Smith uh and another
judge in New York uh who was briefed by
EFS judge orenstein
um so doj once it was caught out using
this uh Authority that's plainly limited
to retrospective historical surveillance
to do this prospective real-time
surveillance they shifted their strategy
and re-characterized what they'd been
doing before and began instead applying
uh not for de-orders alone but what we
are now calling hybrid orders
um
and this is a never before seen cludge
that combines a prospective pen register
order uh with a slightly higher showing
required by a d-order Susan Susan is
aptly described this as taking one zero
that doesn't authorize cell tracking and
another zero that also doesn't authorize
cell tracking and then combining them to
somehow add up to one that does
authorize cell tracking
um someone can correct me here I've been
off the beat for a little bit but there
have been somewhere between two and
three dozen cases at this point lower
court cases considering uh the Hybrid
Theory and many have accepted it though
most have rejected it sometimes after a
briefing from eff ACLU and or CDT and
sometimes in the strongest terms here
are just a few of the choice adjectives
some of them coming from Judge Smith
um
contrived unsupported misleading a
chimera a Hail Mary play perverse
um and my favorite and I'm not sure if
this was Judge Smith or not a statutory
Frankenstein that the government is
stitched together from ill-fitting parts
that was not mine
so but as far as we know at this point
and like with the storage cell site
stuff uh very Little's changed doj still
routinely uses these non-probable cause
hybrid orders to track cell phones
magistrates still routinely issue them
and we think that the phone companies
routinely accept them meanwhile and and
uh more like in the email context the
doj has refused to appeal any of these
uh cases questioning their Hybrid Theory
perhaps in recognition of just how weak
it is
um so we both the public and the
magistrates are kind of wandering around
in the dark on this one which is
basically the theme of an article I
wrote for a symposium of Susan's years
ago that recounts the history of this
real-time tracking issue and the secrecy
that surrounds it and pretty much all
other law enforcement legal theories and
practices when it comes to electronic
surveillance
um I'm a little bit embarrassed by it as
my first Journal uh effort but sugoian
tells me it's worth reading and I try to
avoid arguing with Chris unless I
absolutely have to so
um
in the meantime and on that note now
that I've explained just uh what an
Unholy and depressing mess the state of
the law is on these issues I'll turn it
over to my fellow panelists and we can
maybe try and make some sense of it and
chart a way forward thank you and thanks
for keeping your promise exactly on time
Stephanie I and we're gonna
change this from sort of long
presentations to a more sort of
conversational format based on some
planted questions by the panelists ahead
of time and also some of my follow-ups
uh one one of the things that you've
expressed interest in is
is essentially the obfuscation
of what the government is doing when it
applies for uh this kind of location
data when it asks for it that that the
implicit requirement is for a magistrate
like judge Smith
to have considerable technical knowledge
or to go out affirmatively and and seek
it explain what's happening there and
why that matters
sure and let me just start by saying as
Kevin gave a little bit of his
background and how he came to this issue
I was a federal prosecutor for a number
of years and then had the Good Fortune
to be detailed to the house Judiciary
Committee when the digital due process
effort started and
the committee has started to consider
how to reform ekba and um I will agree
with Kevin that the content fix has
presented a much clearer path than the
location fix
and I became frankly more educated from
folks like Matt Blaise who started
talking about what this technology does
and what it can have the potential to do
in the future and I thank Chris because
what he explained this morning vis-a-vis
single cell tower data and even
historical location information about
single cell tower data that is the
product of a MicroCell a Pico cell and a
femtocell that that technology can
produce extremely precise data that
fact has
played or how you may say not played
into well to what I would characterize
as how doj has chosen to litigate these
cases and and even represent to
Congressional staff about the lay of the
land vis-a-vis
um what the standard should be for
location data so let me now directly
answer your question with that intro
um
doj has taken the position both from a
perspective standpoint and with regards
to historical location information that
the data is very imprecise and because
it is imprecise they do not need a
warrant now they have conceded that when
they are getting GPS data and
prospectively tracking they do get a
warrant the problem is as Matt Blaise
testified to the committee about and as
Chris aptly summarized this morning that
is not the case for the state of the
technology
so that uh and I I know
judge Smith I'm not I'm going to force
you to talk about the the fifth circuit
case but in that case
um which was an appeal of three orders
that judge Smith had issued vis-a-vis
government requests for historical
location data when they just wanted to
use a d order
judge Smith denied those requests he was
going to require a warrant and and one
of the reasonings that it reasons that
he he relates in his opinion is because
of the state of the technology doj if
you read their brief on appeal to the
fifth circuit
basically represents that in these
particular orders the historical
location data is very imprecise and they
um suggest that that they put forth an
affidavit for Metro PCS and they suggest
that if a court a Magistrate Judge like
judge Smith were to held a hearing on
um the other two orders that the
T-Mobile network information would be
equally imprecise well that may be the
case
in these three particular situations but
the way that doj is sort of pushing
their litigation and ultimately pushing
the law sort of suggests that we are
putting magistrates judges like judge
Smith in the position of literally
having to look at maps of cell towers
every time they
um have to determine whether doj can get
information with a deodor with a hybrid
order or with a higher warrant standard
I respectfully submit to you that that
while our our judges are quite able
um requiring them to look at maps of
cell towers where a new femtocell May
pop up as Chris explained anytime
someone receives it in the mail is just
no way to run a railroad and it is
creating
a body of law that is just a a legal
landscape that's nothing more than a
mess is it a body of law or is it a
body of practice given that they're so
little published on this well you're
you're getting various decisions doj
relies on one most of them right now are
Magistrate Judge decisions but goj for
example relies on a 2005 decision from
Judge gorenstein to be not Ornstein not
Ornstein but gorenstein with G from 2005
where he is literally examining the map
of cell towers in at that time uh the
particular area of Manhattan and
determining that single cell tower data
is not very precise so judge Smith in
some Congressional testimony that he
gave documented I've lost count as to
the number of cases but
um at least a major State magistrate and
District Judge body of law where these
these decisions are coming out in
different ways and
um really creating no clear rules for
any of the stakeholders at issue here
beat them lawn enforcement be them
judges be them litigants be them
industry who I know Ed will talk about
further but but they too if you want
them to push back they need clear laws
to understand but are you saying and
could you document that the justice
department in your old uh your old shop
is uh is is misrepresenting the facts is
making knowingly false statements about
the technology and that that a
Magistrate Judge would or could find
that if
if that a person had sort of the
unreasonable burden on him or her to
look into it well insofar as for example
in the circuit case doj is addressing
the technology at issue in those very
applications
it would be hard to
say that that was alive that if that's
what you are really asking what they're
telling other magistrates but in insofar
as they may be for example representing
to Congressional staff or relying on
opinions that suggest that that networks
have a certain level of capacity that is
always imprecise
um yes I think that that is a bit
disingenuous
I've seen them cite FCC studies from 10
years ago about the accuracy of cell
track interesting
I'm gonna I'm gonna go now to judge
Smith and don't worry Adam I'm coming
back to you uh
and by the way his uh his colorful
writing is not limited to opinions uh
he's got two published articles uh with
titles that gagged sealed and delivered
the other one is standing up for Mr
nespit which we have any Monty Python
fans here will recognize as the guy who
tries to hide behind the bush
uh and uh in any event uh
I wanted to ask you
why it is that there are so few reported
decisions on this and whether uh it's
possible for anyone outside uh
the justice department or anyone at all
given that there are other authorities
seeking the location data to know how
how often it happens and under what
pretexts
yeah uh first of all
I want to make clear that I'm anything I
say I'm not commenting on the case
before the fifth circuit or any pending
cases uh and that's not my uh not my
concern here and nor am I advocating for
a particular standard one way or the
other my decisions I mean I published
them for the uh for the reason that I
wanted there to be discussion and for
the pellet course to tell me well how I
got it wrong so I'm not going to gonna
deal with those issues here but but
um
a couple of concerns I mean it's
definitely referred to this body of law
that's now out there with regard to
uh tracking and and it is not really a
body of law there are a bunch of
Magister judges and a few District
judges who have opined on what the
standards ought to be uh but right now
there's no appellate guidance as to what
the standards really are so really we
have a situation where each Magistrate
Judge is basically a law unto himself if
they choose to to agree with me they can
if they choose to agree with judge
gorenstein they can and and uh Grant the
orders uh and and you don't really know
based on I mean there as was mentioned
there are probably a couple of dozen
decisions published and all in feds up
second
some just on West law that addressed the
topic but there's no way of knowing who
what the real majority view is I would
say that with regard to prospective
tracking the majority of published
decisions require a warrant but I cannot
say that all Magister judges or the
majority of them require warrant because
I mean frankly magistrate judges to
speak up for my colleagues I mean we're
fairly busy people and we don't have the
luxury very often of sitting down and
writing an opinion uh every time one of
these things crosses our desk one of
these applications across our desk I
mean we'll get when I'm on criminal Duty
I get two or three of these every day uh
but they they could be rejecting them
without published opinions absolutely
but you don't think they are in very
large numbers I well don't I don't think
so but but again you know nobody really
knows because nobody's really done the
survey now as your question is why
there's so few appeals uh but the you
know appellate courts
cannot decide cases that are not
appealed if there's no appeal filed
there won't be a decision that's just
basic uh and ekta orders are rarely if
ever challenged the only party really in
position to appeal is the government
because they're the one in possession of
the facts and they know what the
Magistrate Judge has done
uh and so it kind of resolves to that an
old saw that only the party that could
appeal won't and only the party that
would appeal can't and the reasons for
that are that what I call ekma's regime
of secrecy I think they're basically
three components to that one the first
is the gag order because when we issue
these orders uh we always require
uh non-disclosure by the provider to the
provider's customer
and they're good reasons for that at
least on a temporary basis I mean
there's no point in getting uh location
data especially if you're tracking
somebody on an ongoing investigation
going to tip them off well that's going
to blow the investigation so the good
reason is at least for temporarily
keeping the providers from telling the
customers that they're getting access
now the the problem is well when are
they going to learn about it well if if
the if the case ultimately ripens to a
criminal prosecution and the defendant
is charged then you would think that
they would get that information that
these orders would be provided to them
uh but even even then it's not there's
not much the defendant can do because
there's no suppression remedy under equa
I mean if the the violation assuming
there's a violation Rises to the level
of constitutional violation then I guess
you know they can they can file a motion
to suppress but again that's all after
the fact now
so that's only to people who have been
charged for the crime they might find
out about these orders that the
government has looked at your email your
cell phone uh accounts if you are a law
abiding citizen and you are not charged
with a crime you will not know you will
never find out
not only because of these gag orders
preventing the provider from telling you
but because these orders are concealed
from the public because they are sealed
and again for good reason you don't want
to blow a criminal investigation
the the problem is that they are as they
come to a manager judge they we seal
them for an indefinite period of time
typically the language is until further
order of the Court well
as a practical matter our Magister judge
who issues one of these orders never
sees that order or that case again
we just don't I mean because no no
defendant has been charged yet there's
no real case going on and so you know
things just move on down the line so I
have that Canadian referencing it from
what you just said a moment ago are you
really willing to stipulate uh that uh
and I'm I'm not a lawyer so I'm about to
start messing up all my all my legal
language but are you willing to accept
that
uh in all cases or in general uh there
are good reasons that the uh that the
subject of the uh of the data request
should not know it I mean as Chris
generally good reasons for them not to
know it before the request is executed I
think they ought to have a right to be
advised and give a notice sometime after
it's executed in fact even in a wiretap
statute
the uh even someone who's who's a target
of a wiretap is entitled to know about
the wiretap within 90 days after the
wiretap is completed now as a practical
matter the government can get extensions
of that 90-day period so I don't know in
practice you know how often they do but
I mean somebody that's a target of a
wiretap ultimately is going to be
charged and so they're probably going to
learn about it but but for historical
location data in a case where someone
already knows he or she's under
investigation why is it any different
from the search warrant that was taped
to Chris sagorian's kitchen table
um well good question I mean often the
the rationale that's presented to me is
that well where there are other targets
to the investigation we don't want to
tip them off
uh you know we don't want to to make
this publicly available because we got
an ongoing investigation and so you know
as a practical matter what I try to do I
have resisted issuing indefinite ceiling
orders for these things I put a 180 day
time limit on it and then
uh ask the government if to tell me if
they still need it sealed beyond that
point if there's still an ongoing
investigation or somebody may be at risk
of physical harm or or you know witness
might flee or something that sort they
can show something to me then I will I
will extend it but ordinarily
um that's that's my practice that is not
the general Practice in fact you know I
did a little research and we've got in
our court uh pen registers issued back
in 1995 that are still sealed and I'm
quite confident that those criminal
investigations are long since completed
I think I think I need to uh get added
to this conversation uh and one reason
I'm really glad you're here is that
there's sort of no point in having
panels all day where no one disagrees
with anything and I'm not assigning you
a role to disagree but but I'm going to
rule out of order for all of us uh Eddie
uh comments that sort of fail to note
areas of disagreement I mean let's air
them here one one thing I'm curious
about it is based on a little experiment
I did about a year ago I
you know as a reporter I asked each of
the major telecommunications companies
and isps you know going through public
affairs a number of questions including
what their standards were
and whether they uh since they're not
always Bound by the sixth circuit or
third circuit opinions we've been
talking about whether they choose that
interpretation or the doj interpretation
when they respond to requests and a good
number of them simply they didn't answer
at all and the ones who did answer said
blah blah blah blah blah we're not
answering uh so Delights not to answer
uh so uh
why shouldn't uh your clients I'll put
it that way uh
feel obliged to tell us what their legal
standards are when disclosing our data
okay
um I'll uh answer that in traditional DC
fashion by first not answering it
um
I'm at sidley Austin and so if it were
I'm one of the global coordinators of
privacy data security information law
practice
and really it is a global practice
because most of these issues are in
practice
Global when companies are deploying
things it's not just about U.S law it's
about Elon other Norms
um I also should mention that I'm
speaking for myself not for any clients
or any carriers um I have advised
carriers in the past but I you know if
we're going with Star Wars theme I don't
want the Darth Vader music to
uh we'll make everyone sign a waiver on
the way out okay okay
um
I think that there is a real desire on
the part of at least telecommunication
carriers generally to have
um Clarity on these issues I think
they're a line with the digital due
process Coalition uh so remember members
of that and um there is a tremendous
amount of kind of retail privacy that
goes on
um one of the things about being in
private practice is uh you deal with
actual operations and you see that most
of these processes when they come in
from the courts uh go to a series of
Clerks and the clerks are processing
them and sometimes it's self-service and
they want a clear rule the carriers want
a clear Rule and they want to comply
with that rule
um and so I've seen actually some
clients say
uh listen we're just it's just too
uncertain just ask for a warrant on
location data just because there's too
much uncertainty and if they can't get a
warrant maybe let's drop it or push back
or maybe we'll come back with award in
which case is fine uh I've seen one one
of the uh
this little cheat sheets one of the ones
I love best
um what was the standard for location
data the means to which government
authorities can obtain location data is
complicated must be evaluated In Case by
case basis looking at constitutional
privacy rights and some statutes
right I'd love to get a copy of that
we got a chart right here it looks
really handy and uh it is really handy
um and uh I thought wow what if you're
the clerk sitting there trying to answer
that that's not a very helpful it's like
go talk to the lawyers about it and I
think that's how it comes to so maybe
when they're not answering the question
they're being honest but if I could get
the mouse for one second I did want to
put some other players on the market
here because if you're in private
practice excuse me can you escape
I don't think up
maybe yes okay can I do the mouse from
down here
all right
because I want to put this of course we
allow why not
so we've been focused I want to talk
about location privacy and put everyone
else out because if you didn't take his
guidance and destroy your iPhone you'll
see that there's two little things that
says I've got three bars
and then there's another thing the Wi-Fi
signal right
and the Wi-Fi location is even much
tighter it's not some feminine cells
might be a little bit closer but the
locate the Wi-Fi signal is as important
and internet companies Gathering
location information can be as
significant a source of information
about location
and that's the thing is that we're
focusing on Telecom because there's law
there there's equa but on for much of
the money the people who have location
data are not covered by ekba people
concerned about credit cards but there's
riftpa there
but we don't have that here so this is
this Loom escape and this is a uh
something that's used in the online
advertising industry
uh this is for mobile everyone involved
in taking mobile marketing and giving it
to a consumer and you see that the
carriers well the carriers are up there
but there are tiny little portion of
this and then there are all these
companies down here location-based
service apps location technology
companies
there are all these companies that are
out there and it would be a whole
seminar to explain how they all interact
and it's quite complex my point being
that there are many other sources of
location information that would be
available to law enforcement and those
sources of location data aren't under
the regulatory scheme the Telecom
carriers or the credit card companies or
the banks are
and so although you might be interested
in how the carriers are responding to it
to my mind the worrying thing is how the
other companies are responding to it
because those location-based companies
then take that information and one of
the main uh consumers of that
information is DHS it feeds back into
the government
and that data does not have any process
to it and they say well why can't we
have the same information that some guy
trying to sell you a Serial ad has so
that's really interesting and uh I want
that seminar on the slide uh
but I want to press you on the uh on
part of the original question uh
look they're a constitutional their
statutory their regulatory mechanisms
that could address these issues but
they're also Market mechanisms that
could in theory but we don't have the
transparency that would allow that to
happen so judge Kaczynski can decide how
much he's willing to pay for privacy and
each of us can do that but we have no
way of shopping for privacy because the
uh the companies
involved won't tell us what their
practices are with with some exceptions
like Google and Twitter uh so uh sort of
as as good Market
the capitalists uh wouldn't it be
wouldn't it be the right thing for the
companies to make more information
available about okay they they want
clear standards but what are their
practices now
there are efforts some it depends on how
they want to Market themselves among the
even Telecom carriers which are over
there I know everything's hard to see on
that
even among the tocos there are different
there are much more privacy protective
as I said one of one of them just says
get a warrant it's unclear just get a
warrant and can you say which one no
they should say that people would like
that yeah and there's that
um there is right now a big experiment
on this right now Microsoft is trying to
advertise its privacy protected status
I mean they're they're if I don't know
if you've seen they don't get scruggled
campaigns they are trying to argue that
their search results are cleaner their
data handling is better than Google's
and they're trying to sell Microsoft
Bing as against Google
which we'll see how much traction that
gets but there are efforts I mean
companies are trying to do it the
question is are consumers and this goes
to the point judge Kaczynski made
are consumers going to buy it I mean
what is the price at what is the price
for privacy is it you want to get free
free ads for Starbucks as you're walking
by
well then I need to know you're walking
by Starbucks right well but I'll open
this up to everybody but uh it's true
that sometimes you know there's there's
uh I guess it was Bruce Schneider's
famous
comment that if uh if you're not paying
for the service you know something like
Facebook you're not the customer you're
the product uh
and that goes to the subsidy idea but
I'm paying plenty for this probably two
thousand dollars over the life of the
contract but uh Verizon Wireless in my
case you know figured they're leaving
money on the table if they don't also
sort of sell me uh and one one of the
issues here for the companies is
I mean the government can ask for all
kinds of historical location data but uh
if the companies didn't keep it it
wouldn't be there uh and the companies
keep it for their own commercial reasons
primarily
so I mean do you see a conflict of
interest between the companies and their
customers on something like that
I think I mean this is when the carriers
signed on to the digital due process
Coalition I think that was a good faith
uh well-intentioned effort to try to get
some clarity and as much as we are
worried about the courts and uh fighting
over it I think the fight would be much
easier if Congress
um
um got onto the field here and we had a
senator somewhere
who would put a locational Bill a
location privacy Bill forward
um and and clarify that and I think the
carriers would would go with that
you almost can't touch that that would
be a great segue to discuss what's
happening on the hill but before we do
that I just want to talk a little bit
more about the transparency issue
um because you know we do have this
uh great effort from a number of
companies to try and be more transparent
we're seeing numbers from from Google
and Twitter we're seeing from Twitter
them starting to be more clear about
what their standards are for for all
their data Google has said what their
positions are on some data as of some
other companies that I mentioned
um
and it's worth noting that by disclosing
what standards you are holding your
company to you can help establish the
norm you can actually help create the
rule when there is not a clear rule
that's been established or at least been
established for the entire country and
you can help create the norm when you're
public about that but and then there's
simply the issue of numbers
um you know right now we're starting to
see more internet companies give numbers
voluntarily when it comes to the
carriers we only got them when when Mrs
Marky and Barton uh pressed for them and
then we got them back
um very inconsistent with the one very
large numbers but also not knowing
exactly how they counted certain things
so that like it's hard to compare one
company to another finally there's a
third aspect of the transparency that's
wholly lacking
um and that is Clarity on what exactly
the records are that are currently being
compiled and held you know we will very
occasionally and Susan knows this as
well as anyone we'll get like a couple
of photocopies of like a Sprint record
from 2008 and that's shown to us as some
evidence of what the state of cell
tracking is and but we don't honestly
know we don't you know we don't have the
barest Fair facts of what exactly of
Verizon or an ATT or any other carrier
or frankly anyone else in this ecosystem
is storing on us and that is a a real
problem
um but yeah so there are some Senators
who've done that uh it's pretty great um
also Senator Leahy uh introduced a bill
a couple of years ago at this point um
that both warrant for content and
warrant for uh tracking of a cell phone
but did not for prospective track while
tracking yes
uh for tracking of a cell phone
prospective tracking a a of a cell phone
but but did not introduce a warrant
requirement for stored records
um uh a couple of uh folks saw that bet
and raised it
um Senator Wyden and representative
Chaffetz uh bipartisan team up
um introduced a bill called the GPS act
there's now also uh co-sponsored or
hopefully when it is reintroduced will
be co-sponsored uh by Senator Kirk that
would require a uh warrant for real-time
tracking or access to stored records
um as I said before the heat right now
is on is on content there was a Content
fix that passed out of the Judiciary
Committee
um Senate side last year we are hoping
that will happen again and we're hoping
it'll get even farther this year whether
and how location is going to mix with
that we don't yet know as I noted there
are a number of difficulties with the
location stuff that we don't have with
the content fix
um but this is not an issue that is
going away and there is Broad support
from not not only the Privacy groups but
also the carriers themselves to get some
clarity yeah one of my concerns about
the the legislative process which I you
know great I hope the legislature takes
care of it so we don't have to wrestle
with it uh anymore but I'm concerned
that they're legislating on the basis of
not very good uh if any empirical data
because frankly there's no what we do is
magistrate judges in issuing these
orders especially under 2703 they need
there's no tracking mechanism if you go
to our electronic case filing system if
you even if you have a case number all
you will see is sealed event there's no
description publicly available as to
what type of order is issued what type
of crime they're investigating what
agency requested it just basic forms of
information and they're not required
presently by Statute
Congress doesn't require the courts to
report that information now they do
require the courts to report data on
wire tabs and I think that the well doj
is supposed to report on pin registers
but on 20 on the store Communications
act there's no government that there be
any reporting so I'm concerned because I
didn't know I mean I I wrote an article
last year partly to as part of a project
to find out how many of these orders
we're issuing as management judges and I
came to the conclusion and I you know I
had to there wasn't any real uh I wasn't
equipped to do the actual research
myself I piggybacked off a study of
secret cases or seal cases done by the
fjc the Federal Judicial Center in 2006
and with a little manipulation and
extrapolation I came to the number of
probably
uh thirty thousand
secret electronic surveillance orders
issued by magistrate judges every year
now
if you compare that to what the fisa
court does fisa in its entire history
since 1979 has issued about 28 000
orders
so as magistrate judges we preside over
the most secret court docket in America
30 times more secret than fisa and until
we get some way of getting some oxygen
in the system getting some transparency
into what we do I'm concerned that
Congress is legislating from a black box
they're legislating based on you know
hearings and you know and I was invited
to testify and I really appreciated them
I was honored to to give my perspective
but I'm concerned that they're
legislating Without Really knowing
exactly what we're doing because we
don't know what we do because nobody's
tracking it
yeah I mean I'll just add one thing I
mean we agreed not to talk uh much of it
all about the National Security side of
this on this panel but except a note
then you can jump in here if you want
and and Kevin and Ed were on opposite
sides of the atnt uh NSA case which uh
Ed I noticed that his official biography
uh describes as a uh as purported class
actions related to alleged National
Security Programs
uh
but I mean let's also you can also count
national security letters uh on metadata
which
um as opposed to your magistrate
estimate you've got you know in the six
figures uh sort of in in the hundreds of
thousands uh of those and we know even
less about
the uh you know sort of fisa and the and
and what The Clapper case mentioned
briefly as uh fisa exempt forms of
surveillance uh about which we know well
then we don't even know what they're
talking about yeah excuse me the New
York Times last year reported that they
surveyed or based on the information
they got from eight different telecoms I
believe uh that they issued something
like 1.3 million or had 1.3 million
requests every year now it wasn't broken
down so we don't know exactly what type
of request those were but I think you
know probably my account or my estimate
of thirty thousand remember this is back
in 2006 and I don't think they've
diminished at any point since that time
also that just counts federal courts I
don't think the state courts are any
less active than federal courts and
probably more so because they do the
bulk of the Criminal Justice right and
just my last intervention on this is uh
the admirable Google and Twitter
transparency reports um if you ask them
carefully exclude uh any requests that
are made under National Security
authorities oh yeah
they really should make that clear on
the sites but
I just want in terms of adding some some
getting some oxygen in the room this
points to another issue of transparency
with with the companies and not just the
the telcos but everyone
um
these gags are ripe for First Amendment
challenge by the companies that are
prohibited from speaking particularly
the ones that uh last forever or until
further unspecified action of the court
I mean in fact in part based on um not
only just general prior restraint
precedent but some litigation around
nsls and one thing that would be really
good for everyone would be if a couple
of companies picked those fights
um I'd love to talk to anyone who would
like to do that but we haven't really
seen it yet except so far in the in the
NSL context but these pen register gags
are ridiculous Bart can we return back
to the legislative process yes please uh
that was gonna be the last subject I
wanted to cover with you guys and then
we'll open it in a few minutes to the
floor okay
how this
this invites in the best of
circumstances
the various stakeholders who have
equities in the issue Congress perhaps
unlike the courts has the ability to
draw lines in a way that balances those
equities and whatever policy Direction
Congress determines is correct so
in all fairness to Kevin and his his
work on this issue
the Privacy Community is starting from a
position where they want a warrant for
all location data even a single point of
his service community and a t
-claire ATT
has but
let me just say when when
um people come up and Lobby on this
issue at least when I was there the
strongest voices for an all-warrant
standard where the Privacy Community the
problem is the Privacy Community isn't
the only stakeholder here you have law
enforcement as well and they can make a
very compelling argument that a warrant
standard for every type of location data
will inhibit investigations at early
stages and not allow them to build up to
probable cause
um they could even make the argument
that in certain investigations they want
to rule people out of crimes that
arguably is not a rule 41 standard where
you're you're trying you're showing to a
court that you have probable cause that
what you're about to get is evidence of
a crime that's kind of the opposite of
evidence of a crime
um orenker has raised the issue when we
say probable cause and the location
tracking context probable cause of what
is it probable cause that look that the
location data itself is evidence of a
crime or is it something else a
Magistrate Judge in Baltimore issued an
opinion where the government had an
arrest warrant for someone and they
wanted to find him they wanted to Ping
his cell phone to determine where he was
so that that arrest or warrant which was
a finding of probable cause could be
executed this particular Magistrate
Judge read the law to suggest that
because that prospective pinging was not
likely to give evidence of the crime
that this individual was charged and the
arrest warrant even with a warrant the
government couldn't get it the probable
cause standard didn't fit so this is a
very as Kevin said complex issue and you
know if if we want to look practically
down the road and actually change the
law in a way that will help our our
privacy rights we have to deal with all
of the different equities and and law
enforcement has to compromise too but I
think you know outside of the courts if
you're looking for Congress to do this
all of the stakeholders have to realize
they're not going to get everything they
want but if I could ask this facetiously
as a way of getting into the prospects
for legislation I mean I I take it that
you are not especially worried that you
you know Al Franken and the eff CDT ACLU
Juggernaut are going to roll over the
National Security establishment and the
law enforcement establishment uh and and
and their overlapping interests with the
telcos on this one I mean is is there I
mean and the broader question for anyone
who wants to answer it is whether there
is any plausible
counter Force uh uh That Could That
Could allow for the creation of
legislation that would be a meaningful
check on uh this kind of surveillance
a scandal involving a congress person or
a senator that implicates their location
privacy one thing is that
you said the overlapping interest with
the telcos I mean the tocos
I think I have overlapping interest with
their customers because the biggest
thing the the telcos
um will benefit from is that people feel
comfortable using these devices and find
it useful to have the next generation of
technologies that Google Maps works
because it knows exactly where I am and
the Wi-Fi signal is even better because
it pinpoints me even closer
yeah but they can they can obtain that
kind of uh customer confidence by making
sure the customers don't know how much
they're being tracked I mean in fact if
I recall correctly when when uh
Chris recorded and disclosed what Sprint
said was it Sprint or Yahoo that wants
tried to force you sort of to
uh we first need to withdraw what you
were saying or not publish it because if
people knew what they were doing they
would lose confidence in them as a
provider
's surveillance manual Yahoo and Verizon
objectives
just how much they charge the government
and uh Verizon is concerned that people
would call up their customer service and
ask if they're being wires out and Yahoo
is objective because they said that the
information would make them look bad
compared to competitors and they said
that it could be used to shock the
customers
is there anybody else here in the panel
I want to address this and then we'll go
to them and I wanted to respond to what
Stephanie said um because she makes a
very important Point
um it's a tough issue there are a lot of
stakeholders involved this is one of the
reasons why this issue hasn't progressed
as much as the content issue
um you know and I also think it is
important to recognize and be supportive
of the fact that on a privacy issue like
this or you know in any push for social
change there is going to be a spectrum
of groups with a spectrum of strategies
and more or less moderate uh proposals
and that's all to the good and helps
ensure the best result I'm just not used
to the person who's left flanking me
being Chris
um but uh but you know hey I can get
used to it
I mean who's right flanking me I'm sorry
I totally flood the joke um but uh but
yeah the I'm usually Chris is usually
the bomb throw and I'm the more uh
pragmatic one but in this one Chris
Chris and Stephanie together are are a
bit uh less less bomb throwing more
pragmatic which again is good we need
those proposals out there I do want to
respond on the legislative process if
you consider the alternative
um taking it all through the courts in
the Quan oral argument you know the the
court struggled there's a couple
humorous quotes so I'll spare that
um struggled with paging technology
whether people could leave a message on
a pager and such
um in oral argument and it was
um
quite disturbing
um as a lawyer who advises technology
companies because most of the people in
that Loom Escape
um have products that are not really
understood
by most of the people in their companies
and investors I mean it's they're
they're they've got it going and they're
going to see if it gets some traction
and maybe a couple years from now we'll
be talking about them or maybe a couple
years they'll wind up in what they know
uh article but
um that um those companies need clear
guidance need to know the rules of the
road and to the extent we will have on
courts to give us those rules we're
going to be trailing so far that these
companies will be dead before the rules
are clear so we have to go to Congress
and we have to use that mechanism
because we don't really have any other
choice to get a decent sense of how to
protect privacy going forward
so uh state your name please come to a
microphone if you want to ask a question
Chris sagoyan ACLU so last September
when September October when this when
the General Petraeus Scandal blew up and
we we got these details leaked every day
new details about the investigation
through newspapers the the method by
which the FBI was able to finger the the
identity of the person who was who was
using this email account they'd been
sending threatening emails was
fascinating so Ms Broadwell at the time
was on a book tour and so she was using
Wi-Fi at various hotels the email
account that she was using was not
registered with her name
um and she wasn't even using the Wi-Fi
in her room which might there may be
records linking her room to her uh her
name instead she was just logging in
from the hotel lobby at these various
hotels around the country and the way
the FBI traced the account to her
identity was by sending requests to all
the hotels that that had Wi-Fi where
she'd like where the percent login from
and requesting the full guest list
and with these various hotel guest lists
they then looked for common names and
realized that she was the only common
name on the various guest lists now this
technique in this case was about hotels
but this is the exact same technique
that the government uses to identify
people with cell tower dumps right where
they get the lists of everyone who's
been there a few locations and looks for
common names and in the Broadwell
investigation you had a lot of really
innocent people who had done nothing
more than go to a hotel
who's whose names and other information
ended up in an FBI database and in the
case of cell tower dumps everyone but
the target the eventual Target is
innocent and their name ends up in a
government database
from my perspective as a privacy
Advocate cell tower dumps are easily the
most problematic form of location
request yet because they are normally
about a very short period in time they
don't get the same kind of protection
that say alito's concurring opinion
would lead you to believe that location
data gets after a certain number of days
what can we do about location data about
large numbers of people do you think
Congress will will deal with this
specific problem or do you think that
when Congress eventually deals with
location data and whether we get a
warrant standard or a super D standard
do you think we will get the same
standard for one person or a thousand
people's data even though there are
special privacy concerns associated with
Tower dumps and if if anybody wants to
address the implications in that
question
of the data retention and sharing
policies of the US government especially
post 911.
I mean if you get a big dump of people
who are not involved in the case
because we worked on an article together
um
standards alone are not going to fix the
problem especially with regards to cell
tower dumps because you are getting such
a broad swath of information so there
are certainly things Congress could do
like requiring minimization minimization
is something that you find in other
Federal statutes like the wiretap act
like even on the National Security side
of things in 215 business record orders
where the government
and is required to essentially take out
of its databases that information which
does not support the efforts or or the
purposes of which The Authority it is
given uh to collect the information is
is necessary on an ongoing basis so
um Congress could act in this area but I
I think honestly this is not something
the government is going to come and
scream oh give us more minimization
requirements
um I think part of the Privacy advocacy
needs to really
um
come forward and say this is as
important as standards because standards
don't fix the fact in the long run that
the government is retaining your data I
there was and perhaps and you can
address this better this recent decision
by doj to retain data for five years
yeah it was the it was the the not I
think it referring to the national uh
kind of terrorism Center and it was a
really Arcane thing there were some
wonderful journalism uh kind of
explaining its significance but I don't
think it's gotten the press it should
have that the um one of the most
important things you've got all these
databases across the federal government
right you've got land records and health
records and everything else and they
National terrorism Center has authority
to pull those records in and to Ping
them against their list of bad guys if I
want a better word answer sees the
information about the bad guys and the
standard had been that they get to hold
those records for six months and this is
all explained out but they've now moved
that standard out to five years
so that the data can be continually
pinged and so there's this Gathering of
information across the government and I
think that probably points it's one
thing is always a privacy act really is
restricting systems of Records to
particular uses
you know restricting government data to
particular uses is a a vital concept
here because we need to have that kind
of restraint within the executive branch
and within law enforcement and I think
this post 911 idea of fusion centers and
bringing everything together and keeping
it together is
um something that that pushes at the
state level and tribal authorities well
exactly I mean the fusion brings it all
together and I think that's one of the
most uh
um I that worries me a lot more than
cell tower dumps
I think the two kind of combine in a
really pernicious way I mean we have the
problem already even so first we have
the investigative technique of getting a
lot of data on a lot of people to try
and like cross-reference and find the
person we're looking for
um the DDP principles try and address
this by at least requiring a court order
before you do something like that
um but other than the cell phone context
we've also seen in a case we handle the
dff uh uh a subpoena for the IP address
of every single person who visited a
particular political news site on a
particular day which is just insane
um then there's the problem even if you
weren't getting these big dumps of the
data they're getting through other
authorities uh most notably pen
registers all getting fed into the same
database and I'm forgetting the name of
this database and maybe Jennifer can
remind me but I'm trying to remember
exactly where I heard about this but
there is an FBI database where all the
pen register results go into
and and so if you've ever communicated
with anyone who was pen registered you
know there is some level of map of your
interactions that's sitting in an FBI
database right now that we have really
no details on
um trying to put minimization rules into
the statutes is a really uh important
way of addressing that problem but
uh
I'm not sure we're gonna get it and in
the meantime
um these databases are getting bigger
and bigger
um and we are knowing less and less
about what's in them
I'm going to just alternate sides here
I have a couple of questions first one's
for judge Smith I'm helping some folks
pushing for legislation in Texas require
warrant for tracking for phone tracking
and one of the provisions in the bill
because right now the orders for mobile
tracking devices like in USV Jones are
sealed forever under the Texas state law
and so we had proposed making it sealed
for 180 days and giving them an option
to expand it for 180 days and it turns
out so far this has been one of the big
points of pushback from law enforcement
is that they're saying well this is not
long enough we have investigations that
go on for years and years investigating
the drug cartels or whoever and I was
interested to hear you say that that you
have been saying 180 days then come back
and ask for longer so I was curious
how often are they needing more than 180
days how long is that in empirically
what kind of what need do they have for
that
um yeah that's a good question I I
started doing that I guess sometime in
2007 2008 and uh
um actually I took it on myself I didn't
I didn't put the burden on the U.S
attorney's office I just every six
months or every year I'd make a list of
all the pin registers that I'd issued
sealed and I sent a letter to the yes
attorney saying here the ones I've
sealed I'm going to unseal them after a
certain day unless you tell me the
investigation is still ongoing or give
me a good reason why it needs to be
continue to be sealed
um and so since I've been doing that I
would say about about half the time they
come back with a request for an
extension uh I haven't been
I would say I I give them a year before
I send my letter out although I say 180
days I get around to it after at the
close of the year so typically my you
know experience uh they want to keep
them sealed for a year or so beyond that
most of the time the investigation is
over with and they don't push back and I
just go ahead and unseal them so
my other question was there was a
distinction being made and of course you
it's common in these debates about
perspective versus historic tracking but
in a context where your smartphone is
checking every couple of minutes for
your email is there really a difference
as a practical matter is I mean if isn't
it historical if it was two minutes ago
and doesn't that still I mean maybe I'm
not understanding the the distinction
but is that um is that really a
meaningful decision it's not your
misunderstood I mean the distinction
between the two is sort of an angel's
dancing on the head of a pen kind of
thing and the doj has in litigation sort
of argue that well we're using these
stored authorities because as soon as it
hits the server it's being stored if
only for a few milliseconds so
hey I mean but I think the main
distinction is like we have these
statutes that are clearly meant to be
ongoing in time in part because they
have things like time limits while we
have these other authorities that are
clearly for like obtaining pre-existing
material that don't have those
protections and that's why the
government has now created this clutch
where they they say well we can take the
you know prospective protections from
pen trap and then tack that on to this
de-order thing
um but
your point is well taken and not at all
your misunderstanding it's a it's a
a deep problem
I'll come back to you if there's time
but that let's let's keep it uh let me
get Alvaro into it sure
um I wanted to ask a factual question so
Ed you made the excellent point that
it's not just the carriers that are
getting location data platform companies
are you know most the biggest ones are
set to by default collect uh Wi-Fi data
for example and then re-transmit it back
to the platform company
um every set period of time apps
obviously uh um get location data
there's a wonderful Wall Street Journal
report about how you know one out of
every two top apps uh in December 2010
not only got the data but then turned
around and transmitted at the third
parties and so the factual question I
have is you know what evidence do we
have or what do we know about whether
law enforcement is querying those
databases
um we know and we have excellent records
thanks to the work of people in this
room about the carrier stuff but um what
do we know about law enforcement
location requests to platform companies
or app companies or any of the other
companies in that ecosystem
I would I would say I'm not gonna I I'm
not gonna answer that directly but I can
say this that a lot of that goes to
building profiles that are mainly
assembled for marketing purposes they
want to just sell you clothes and trucks
and coffee
um but those same profiles are
accumulated from different sources in
the information ecosystem and then you
see the government having contracts
to pull those um profiles in to pull
that information in
um like Axiom is one I think is a pretty
significant Government Contracting
section and so information flows around
the marketing ecosystem into Axiom and
then flows over
um and that's that's the complexity and
and so uh in part I'm saying hey
lighting up in the carriers but the uh
but the other part is saying there's
there's a lot more information out there
and at least the carriers in the banks
their statutes there and there's cases
um the rest of it is uh Wild West uh and
to some significant degree still
hi I have uh two related factual
questions number one let's say an
assistant United States Attorney wants
to engage in real-time cell phone
tracking and has The Misfortune of
drawing on a particular day a Magistrate
Judge who does not Grant those order
unless the government shows probable
cause I'm curious whether anyone knows
whether their policies and procedures in
place that would prevent that assistant
United States Attorney from Simply
refiling that application the subsequent
day when the Magistrate Judge would no
longer be on duty in the hope of
securing a different Magistrate Judge
who did not require such a rigorous
standard and second and relatedly does
anyone have any factual information
about the government's uh whether the
government sometimes files sequential
requests for historical sell site
information to avoid having to meet a
warrant requirement for real-time
tracking
all right everybody's looking at me so I
guess oh yeah
well but just what what that's why just
the first narrow question having been
denied by judge Smith can the government
come back the next day to judge Jones
um I think there's not there's nothing I
know of that prevents it uh other than
the potential displeasure of the
Magister of Judges who find that out and
find out that okay they've gone to
another judge on the same application
they turned you down why are you coming
to me
uh there's there's no I I don't think
the principles of collateral estoppel or
race yudakata apply
and so they can do that but typically
and I have been some I have some concern
about it uh I don't think it's that
practices
necessarily widespread although I will
say that as far as the judge shopping
problem I mean we have five magistrate
judges in Houston and we rotate the
criminal Duty Among Us so there's one
judge on duty for every two weeks and
basically when we're on duty that's all
we do that two-week period and our
schedule is mapped out in advance and
the U.S attorney's Office knows when I'm
going to be on the duty and when the
other ones are not
so uh if you were a prosecutor
uh what would you do but wait if you can
until you know you're going to get
somebody based on experience and and the
prosecutors have no know the management
judges I mean I've I am yeah I've been
on the bench now eight years almost nine
uh three of the other ones in Houston
I've been on this is up there on their
third terms their eight-year term so
they they we all have a track record so
they know and so
and and I've looked at the numbers and
and uh my share of pen register
applications is doesn't equal the the
average that you would get if you you
know if it were completely random I know
that so I don't think I'm speaking out
of schools I think you have some numbers
on that I mean do you want to at least
estimates do you want to do you want to
share this uh well the last time I
checked and I did it for the last two
years uh I think
I I believe the numbers where I got
around eight to ten percent of those
applications whereas you would expect I
would have gotten 20 almost five out of
half as many I get half as many yeah
somebody tweet that
well I mean is that really a surprise
and I'm not surprised but I'm not sure
that there's anything necessarily
nefarious about it it's just
common sense right if you're if you're a
prosecutor if I were a prosecutor I'd
avoid YouTube
how about the other part of the question
about uh sequential historical I've not
not seen that
this is probably a fair amount of
paperwork and so much paperwork involved
I mean it's there's a volume aspect of
this I can't see them doing I mean you
could do sequential sequence
the the judge would finally I think come
back and say I would expect
Council you're here for the third day in
around the same thing
that question might spring to your mind
maybe yeah yeah
and in judge Smith's case they filed an
application for historical records to be
created on an ongoing basis that's what
just what Kevin was asking about
okay so we have another episode of the
last question I just can't resist
telling us so I identify yourself please
oh I'm sorry David Gray uh I can't uh
this is not a new problem of course this
in the days before the sentencing
guidelines
um at least in the southern district of
New York people used to Pile in when the
judge for whom I clerk Charles hate
who's a proud graduate of this law
school was in part one because he was
notoriously light on sentencing so he
had well many more plea agreements on
the days that he was in part one but my
question actually goes to uh Kevin on a
throwaway
um statement you said at the beginning
of your comments which is that we're not
doing our job here unless we lose some
cases along the way and we got a very
different story a couple weeks ago from
Walter Dellinger who was one of the
Architects of Jones who borrowing from
Thurgood Marshall said never never never
lose no matter how small you have to go
go there to win because when you lose
you're done when you win small you
survive to fight another day and in
thinking about his comments and compare
pairing them to yours I wonder which of
the two strategies is better
particularly if we think that there are
radical changes afoot in our
conceptualizations of privacy and our
conceptualizations of the Fourth
Amendment
because if Klein was right then we have
this highly integrated web of beliefs
and we can't change them all at once we
can only change each one of them one at
a time and so if we want to affect the
big changes don't we have to play small
ball and never never lose
um
no uh no I I if if you're if if you're
in the non-profit space if you are a
civil libertarian you know as your job I
think you have to be on the Vanguard and
you have to be making the strongest
arguments and it may take years it may
take decades to actually Prevail on
those arguments and so the job is to
lose until you win but for example
a recent loss uh
eff and ACLU together uh tried to stop a
subpoena to Twitter some of you may have
heard of this it was related to
WikiLeaks we represented brigitta John's
daughter uh
um
uh did I say subpoena yes I'm sorry the
D order to to Twitter
um and we made very aggressive Fourth
Amendment arguments that uh the IP
address logs I.E the the logs of what IP
address the targets were logging into
Twitter from uh were protected by the
Fourth Amendment such that a warrant was
required this is a very aggressive
argument
um but one that is uh you know colorable
and and and I would say you know uh uh
possibly probably correct
um based on the gains that we made in
the two cases I talked about earlier uh
because we have warshok saying that just
because we have this data in the hands
of a third party does not automatically
mean we don't have a reasonable
expectation of privacy in it
um and we have the third circuit saying
that uh data that is that is taken from
you uh that you are not explicitly uh
communicating uh is distinguishable from
from Smith and Miller and so it was
through those wins that we could iterate
towards a stronger Fourth Amendment
argument that we couldn't have made the
year prior
um and so
and we lost that argument we may
eventually win it um but we're never
we're never going to win it if we don't
try sometimes without all the ammunition
we'd like to have
can I flesh out the Walter Dellinger
story a little bit more so it
um Walter Dellinger was co-counsel on
the Jones case and he is a very
distinguished Professor from Duke Law
School
um and I think most of us in the room I
I certainly didn't know that
um he did quite a strategic move in
terms of driving the Supreme Court's
argument in that case
um I think Sila mentioned in her
presentation that early on in the
government's questioning chief justice
Roberts looked at Michael drieben who
was the deputy solicitor general that
morning arguing for the government and
and says what keeps what in your theory
keeps you from putting tracking devices
on our carbs and tracking us and all
driven at that moment could really
respond by saying is the justices of
this court
um and he went on then to explain that
how the Court's precedent under not
allows such tracking in on public
thoroughfares well at the time at least
I think most of us in the audience
didn't know that
um Professor Dellinger had done an
interview with Nina totenberg that aired
the morning of the Supreme Court
argument and in that interview he he put
it out there and he said you know if if
we don't win this case it's going to
mean that the government can track the
Supreme Court Justices with these GPS
enabled devices and Ergo you heard from
Justice Roberts later that morning a
question inspired by Mr dellinger's idea
and so that with Kevin is a very good
Advocate just last night I was telling
him how impressed I was that he got the
third circuit to create even a more
confusion in the law
um
um but but Mr dellinger's strategy
really I think spoke volumes so uh so
NPR Wall Street Journal and Time
Magazine can be Force multipliers for
you but I'm going to try to close this
with one last question and see if you
each want to address it uh
what what one or two legislative changes
uh statutory changes uh uh would you
most want to see and in your case uh
judge Smith just as an analytic Point uh
would uh might address some of the
things that you're talking about uh and
and uh rank it on a scale from Thurgood
Marshall's uh sure thing to snowball's
chance in hell
I'm not going to make predictions about
what A legislature will do and I'm not
going to get involved in advocating what
the particular substitute of Standards
ought to be but but from a structural
uh point of view I think ekpas a main
problem a big problem with that is the
secrecy regime it's set up so that
the statue now it's a complex statute it
rarely gets a pellet review and that's
the way our our process works I mean
it's supposed to work that that when you
pass the statute every statute has rough
edges has gaps and they're not
discovered until they're litigated then
they then they're passed upon by the
courts of appeals ultimately Supreme
Court and then it's a process and then
it's the Supreme Court rules and says
this is what the statute means uh then
if the Congress doesn't like that they
change the statute so I think they're
you know there are three things I think
that would that would Aid this one I
think we need to to limit and actually
eliminate the automatic gag order and
and make it the default rule that there
not be uh uh the gag or at least that
there'd be notice given to the
subscriber or the actual user of the
phone within a reasonable time after the
the order is issued secondly I think we
need to to drastically limit this amount
of ceiling that's done in fact I think
most of these applications uh actually
don't really need to be sealed I mean
they don't all they need to do is redact
the names of the confidential or the
information that that's in there but if
there needs to be sealing it needs to be
for a limited period of time third I
think we need to keep track of what
we're doing and I I proposed my idea is
we need something similar to a civil
cover sheet that we have for civil
litigation with which is the first if
you've ever been if you're a lawyer and
ever filed a case in federal court you
know one sheet of paper you have to file
there's a several cover sheet that
describes what the case is about who the
parties are basis of jurisdiction uh
what type of case it is substantively
and what relief you're asking for just
eight basic pieces of information I
think we can do the same thing on the
warrant side just a warrant cover sheet
so so any every time an application is
made to a Magister judge that gets on
the system that's made public just who
the agency is making the request what
they're asking for uh what what crime
they're investigating what
jurisdictional basis they have for the
request if they want it sealed if they
want to delayed notice just you can do
that on a single sheet of paper and I
think that ought to be uh replace this
sealed event designation on our on our
electronic case monitoring files
so and I think actually I think Congress
could could legislate that courts can do
that on their own too if we want to but
you know it's it's a process so we're
supposed to stop but I want each of you
to answer that and then we'll buy
indulgences so uh my uh my three items
one would be the elimination of the
special treatment of uh 180 days that
strikes me as um absurd in this day and
age it was an artifact of the time when
storage space was awfully expensive and
now storage is essentially free
um the second one is my and that that
could well happen the second one is a
much
um bigger ask is to make all the folks
on the
um the uh the lumoscope the the
PowerPoint I had up there subject to the
same rules
so that the carriers and the platform
providers and the app providers are
subject to the same set of privacy
restrictions and it's against the whole
ecosystem so that you don't have this
heavily regulated uh Telco carrier
dealing with the essentially unregulated
internet company we should have a
similar you know a Level Playing Field
and then let consumers choose from there
and
um the third thing is some way to
accelerate judicial review in this area
um so that we don't have
Quan coming out and giving us guidance
about whether pagers may or may not be a
protected privacy interest when no one's
using pagers anymore
I'll start with minimization because I I
think as the example given by Chris the
cell tower dumps are becoming more and
more useful to law enforcement that we
have to find some way to make sure that
innocent third-party data doesn't remain
in databases for potentially forever so
um at some future time that
that data isn't used in a different
crime and that was and and therefore
um there was no judicial process
um that allowed for the use of that data
and an unrelated investigation
um the reporting requirements I mean I I
very much take judge Smith's point that
Congress right now is trying to
legislate in a space where they don't
have a lot of good information I I mean
I feel like unfortunately if we waited
for only reporting requirements before
we started on other things we'll be here
five ten years from now
um but going forward Congress needs good
information so they know in the future
when if at at any time the equities need
to be rebalanced
um and finally you know clear rules
dealing with law enforcement access to
location data both historical and
perspective that do a fair job of
balancing equities and giving us better
privacy rights
I think those are all fabulous ideas I
support them all as well as the digital
due process principles that you can find
at digitaldue process.org the one thing
I'll throw out in addition
um and this is something I proposed in
my article for all of ecpa I think or
incurred proposed this for the content
regarding parts of ekpa and that is a
suppression rule such that if you obtain
any information in violation of ekpa
that gets thrown out that would prompt a
lot more precedent a lot more facts
coming out of the Court grappling with
those issues
and would create very strong incentives
to actually follow ekpa three things
that we don't really have right now
thank you all for coming thank you thank
you